So,
for the next 20 minutes, we're going to
be picking up where we left off
last time we met.
The
youngsters
we were discussing
the narration of Jibril.
And
in this narration,
one of the great companions of the
prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
tells us
of an incident that happened.
His name is Omar ibn al-Khattab.
He said that while we were seated with
the prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
one night,
a man came into masjid one day.
And he had very, very white clothing.
He had very, very black hair.
And he asked about a few things
regarding Islam.
He asked, "What is Islam?"
He asked, "What is Iman?"
And he asked, "What is Ihsan?"
Now, our prophet
he responded.
And he told him what Islam was. He told
him the five pillars of Islam that we
already covered.
And then he told him about the six
pillars
of Iman.
The six pillars
of faith or belief.
Who remembers what the first pillar is?
Maryam.
Belief in Allah, very good.
What is the second pillar? Tell me.
Belief in the angels.
Spot on. Number three, tell me.
Mhm,
you missed you missed something. Tell
me.
Belief in his books, very good.
We stopped there, didn't we? Belief in
his books, right? Okay.
I'm going to tell you something.
I want you to
memorize this.
Every single messenger
has a book.
Everyone.
Do you know how many messengers were
sent to humanity?
I didn't tell you guys this yet.
I'm wondering if you guys know
how many messengers
were sent.
Whoever was with me last Sunday
in the weekend school should know this
answer.
How many messengers
were sent to humanity?
Messengers.
Tell me.
No.
Maryam.
Tell me.
Rital, huh?
99, no. That's not it.
No. You missed the number before 15.
-huh.
No.
Silly goose, there's a number before 15.
Tell me.
No.
Mhm.
Rital.
No.
Okay, listen. I'm going to tell you the
answer.
315.
You already know this.
You should already know this.
Some of the other little
ankle biters should know this.
315.
So, there are how many messengers?
Now, I didn't say prophets. I said
messengers. There's a difference.
How many messengers, Maryam?
315.
Messengers. Which one was the first one?
It was Noah.
Which one was the last one?
Yes?
[Arabic recitation]
Very good.
So, we know that there are at least 315
books.
Maybe more.
There's no reason a messenger can't be
given more than one book.
But,
at least
there were how many books?
315. Okay.
Now, out of all those 315 books,
five of them are mentioned in the Quran.
Five.
Five books are mentioned in the Quran.
What are the names of these books?
Let's see who knows.
The Quran, obviously. That's one. That's
self-evident. Number two.
The Torah. Very good. Number three.
Al Injil. Very good.
Number four.
It was a book that was given
to Dawud alayhi salaam. Tell me, Hussam.
Az-Zabur. Very good.
Very good.
Now, number five.
Who can tell me number five?
If you tell me number five, it'll knock
my socks off.
If you tell me number five, I'll quit my
job, leave town, and never come back
again.
[Arabic recitation]
Which one is it?
Listen closely. I'm going to give you
the answer.
You want to know the answer so that
when we're giving out prizes
for answers,
you know the answer to unlock the
candy or whatever it is.
It is the
Suhuf
of Ibrahim.
Suhuf, you know what Suhuf means?
Suhuf is Arabic for the pages of
Ibrahim.
The scrolls of Ibrahim.
So it is the the scrolls of Ibrahim.
So
the Quran was given to who?
[Arabic recitation]
The Injil was given to who? This this
row of little guys, come here. Come sit
here. Come up front. Come come.
No, not you. You you could stay where
you are. These guys back here. Stand up.
Stand.
-huh. Come sit on this line right here
in front of me.
Yes.
One more. One more line.
Come on, guys. Sit right here.
Yeah. Sit right here.
Button your shirt up. What's going on
here? You taking your clothes off?
Button your shirt up.
Button it up.
Sit right there.
Okay? You sit right here.
Come.
Sit right here.
Very good.
What's up with everybody
unbuttoning their clothes?
What about you? Button your clothes up.
Okay.
The Quran was given to who?
[Arabic recitation]
The Taurat was given to who, Maryam?
Musa alayhis salaam. The Injil was given
to who?
La. Try again. The Injil was given to
I-
Isa. Okay.
And
the Zabur was given to who, Hussam?
Dawud. Very good.
And what is the last one, Maryam?
Suhuf Ibrahim, which means what in
English?
The pages. It also means what? Scrolls.
You guys know what a scroll is?
Yeah, you roll it up.
It's in you know, you see in the
video games or the movies.
Right?
Okay.
[Arabic recitation]
We know where they came from. We know
who gave them to them.
But we don't know the other books.
[Arabic recitation]
But what we knew what we do know, and
this is very important.
All of the important meanings
that are in those other books
are all in the Quran.
So if you want to read all the books,
read all the important stuff
that you need to know,
do you have to read any of the other
books?
You just have to read the Quran. It has
all the meanings that are important to
us in that one book.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sent these
books down.
And each book has its own thing.
for instance,
the the Torah,
Allah wrote the Torah
with his own hand.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Allah wrote the Torah himself.
Gave it to you.
Who?
Mhm.
Musa alayhis salaam. Very good.
The Injil
was given to Isa.
But the Injil was really a continuation
of the Torah. You know what a
continuation means?
You have Torah is one.
volume one.
And the Injil is volume two.
They finish each other.
Both of those two, they make a whole.
And between those two was a Zabur.
Okay.
What is the next pillar of belief,
pillar of faith? We said belief in
Allah, belief in the angels, belief in
the books, belief in the
[Arabic recitation]
Now,
right?
Khalil and Yusuf.
Come on up.
Sit right here, big tough guys.
[Arabic recitation]
One there and one right next to him.
Yes.
Front and center.
Come over here, sit next to him there.
We only got about 5 minutes left. Okay.
Now,
how many messengers were there?
315. Now, listen to how many prophets
there were.
Do you know?
No.
You're not even close.
You're off by about
Oh, more than 120,000. Tell me.
[Arabic recitation]
Is that a lot of messengers? That's a
lot of prophets, right?
124,000.
So, if there was only 315
messengers,
but 124,000
prophets,
that means that there must be a
difference between prophets and
messengers, right? Okay.
I'm going to tell you the difference
right now.
There's a lot of differences, but the
main difference,
listen closely.
The main difference between a prophet
and a messenger
is messengers are sent
to people that worship idols.
People that do not believe in Allah, or
if they believe in Allah, they worship
other things. They worship the sun, they
worship the moon, they worship statues,
they worship saints, they worship the
angels, they worship the jinn, they
worship devils. All kinds of people
worship all kinds of things.
And if people are not Muslim at all,
and they worship other than Allah,
Allah sends what to them?
[Arabic recitation]
messenger.
He sends a messenger to them.
But prophets
prophets is different. Prophets are sent
all throughout
They're sent to
to people that believe in Allah. People
that already follow messengers. Do you
understand? So, Musa Alayhis Salaam was
a messenger and then when people
believed in him, prophets were sent to
lead after he died. Different prophets
were sent to lead Bani Israel. Do you
understand the difference?
How many
messengers, Yusuf?
15. How many prophets?
That's a very strange number. Where did
you get that number, my son?
Tell me.
124,000.
That means 1 2 4 0 0 0. 124,000.
Okay.
What is the next
pillar
of faith?
We got about 4 more minutes. Who can
tell me?
Yes.
It's belief
in a certain kind of day.
Belief in a certain kind of day. Tell
me.
No.
Belief in
Yeah.
The day of judgement.
The last day.
You know what it means? The day of
judgement is just it sounds like.
Hey, sit up.
You want me to get you a pillow and a
blanket?
Sit. Sit. Sit.
belief in the day of judgement
means
that after we all die
everybody here is going to die
eventually.
Everyone you've ever met is going to
eventually die.
Just people that were before us,
they died.
And the people that come after us,
they're going to die. Because dying is
part of living as a human, right? It's
part of our life. Imagine
if there was no death.
You just live forever on Earth.
Exactly. Your your life wouldn't have
any meaning anymore.
You wouldn't have any meaning.
It wouldn't matter if you got Imagine if
it never rained outside and it was sunny
and beautiful and perfect every single
day.
What would happen?
Huh?
No, I mean if it if it was beautiful
outside every day, perfect weather,
perfect.
What would happen?
[Arabic recitation]
You'd never even be able to
appreciate
the nice days.
If you never knew what it was to be
sick,
would you ever be happy and thankful
that you're healthy?
No, because you don't even know what it
means to be sick or healthy. You have to
have the opposite.
Winter makes summer nice.
Unless you're in Arizona, in which case
summer makes winter nice, right?
Rain makes the sun shine nice.
And cold makes warmth nice,
right? Hunger
makes your food taste good.
Doesn't it?
Thirst
makes water taste good.
Doesn't it? Makes it feel nice when you
drink it. Imagine if you drank water and
you never felt thirsty ever.
You'd never be able to enjoy it. Imagine
if you never got hungry. Would you ever
enjoy your food?
No.
And the same thing goes with death.
Death is not a bad thing.
Death is what makes your life
meaningful.
good. It's what makes you
[Arabic recitation]
have to die.
Now, after we all die and we're all in
our graves,
we are all going to be
brought out of our graves
and brought back to life.
And then we're going to come in front of
Allah one by one. Each person one by
one.
And we're going to be judged by Allah
for the things that we do.
And that is why it's called the day of
what?
[Arabic recitation]
Judgement. The day of what?
Speak.
Yes. Judgement.
It's the day of what?
Judgement.
Judgement. The day of what?
Judgement. What's it called?
The day of judgement. The day of what?
-huh. The day of what?
What's it called, Hussam?
The day of judgement when Allah judges
us all.
And nobody's going to be there with you
to help you.
Your mom, your dad, they got to get
judged, too.
You can't help them and they can't help
you.
Who's the only one that can help you on
the day of judgement? Tell me.
Allah
is the only one that can help you on the
day of judgement. And we're going to
stop right there.
You guys are starting to wiggle around
you got ants in your pants.
So, we're going to stop there and I will
see you guys next week. Make sure
that you read the narration before you
come. Have mom and dad read it to you
before you come. You understand?
Okay, guys.
See you later. See you next time.
[Arabic recitation]